South Park is back for season 20 and I
can't wait to see what crazy intro they
came up with today's title sequence is a
whole lot different than 1997's version
let's take a look at the biggest changes
the intros of season 1 through 4 looks
similar
Kyle Stan Cartman and Kenny are all
headed to school and we slowly get
characters added over the years such as
the infamous Antonio Banderas blow-up
doll check out his chest hair some jock
officers and spaceships in the Far
background the rainbow-colored book
tastic bus passing across the screen a
volcano exploding after season 1 by
season 3 we get a glimpse of the chef's
aid concert and in a bit of
foreshadowing Kenny is touched by the
Grim Reaper by season 4 the intro was
chaos it wasn't until the eleventh
episode of the fourth season that we see
our first major chain an explosion kicks
off the boys entrance into the fourth
grade the music changes to a hip-hop
techno mashup straight out of the year
2000 it's a techy intro with 3d models
of the boys some stats and highlights
from past shows oh my god they killed
Kenny you following Kenny's death at the
end of season 5 the show went all arts
and crafts on us season six through 11
started with summons hands making stand
out of construction paper a montage of
previous seasons follows and the title
sequences end on a crowd full of South
Park's vast library of characters this
crowd expands year to year and only
season six features a confident butters
showing off his own handmade sign a year
later we get Kenny's return as he climbs
his way onto the South Park sign be
careful up there Kenny on to season 12
the title begins by zooming out of
Stan's eye and continues with clips from
old episodes the boys fly across the
screen at random angles as they sing
along to the theme between seasons 14
and 16 we get a change in the character
intermissions as they are based on old
clips Stan and Kyle from the elementary
school musical
Cartman in the [ __ ] costume and Kenny at
the Jonas Brothers concert again the
sequence ends with even more additions
to the crowd like Snooki in season 15
intro
but then comes season 17 the intro has
an awfully familiar feel but it's an
entirely new three-dimensional South
Park look closely that's Kenny's grave
over there and there's Marvin Marsh
reading a newspaper with the headline
who is mysterion the sequence ends
similarly but this time the boys climbed
the school roof while the crowded cast
of characters forms behind them there
were a few moments when we had custom
intros for the first season's Halloween
episode I still have no idea why Stan
was the only one with a pumpkin for a
head 16 Halloween's later the goth kids
took over the intro and for the first
time ever the lyrics were changed poser
spouting let's go shopping there was
also a hilarious game of Thrones
inspired intro with the boys dressed for
Westeros we've seen a ton of changes
from the first season and here's hoping
for something brand new to celebrate
season 20 oh no I just said cult or
peach it was it helped me get my stuff
why did I listen to Colin Kaepernick
he's not even any good oh I just got my
stuff back cops are pigs again